welcome to this video playing swap yeah
darshan master Miller good liar and
forgot the Mateus when I I wasn't sure
about the first name okay so let's see
what we can do am playing a bit quicker
than usual trying this and this strategy
out that's an interesting line with 97 k
and coming now iam so going to take here
or not if he takes politics I don't know
don't know before it's not a line I do
play regularly but it recently was
something that a student of mine showed
me it showed me some ideas that he that
he has enough found it interesting and
so I'm just giving it a go without
knowing too much about it an idea three
because I didn't want to see Bishop g4
with that pin handling try and form
Bishop a three to activate the bishop
and again trying to be quick about it
k a five Bishop c5 how said something
that makes some sense let's try that you
cannot take se7 then hangs
so Bishop c5 this night xe5 so that's
not a good idea dear for hangs though
hmm so you really threatening to take it
here maybe air so hmm oopsie 595 gu5
rook c5 there's really no tactical
justification hmm interesting okay let's
just protect a fire for the moment
can still not go Bishop c5 okay so this
is just become irrelevant after you got
b6 CMC's is going for them past be the
past be Paul hmm ok didn't think about
that move at all but it does make some
sense of course night on c4 anyway 9 p-3
yeah III everybody sees that besides me
mmm yeah gifting away games here sure
sure sure just thinking about nights if
I had the strategic idea as usual but
just the kindergarten night b3 I didn't
think about yeah now that's so easy
everybody wins it brooksy to and I'm
completely passive with that bishop but
I couldn't really do anything else
not evening even threatening bishops III
because it can go gay three just
remarkably bad disposition bishops III
again I cannot play because of okay
three whether it is hanging so
it sounds me but it actually was the
worst before I mean it's not completely
lost but i think the position was even
worse at one point so taking 1c3 anyway
for me maybe here tweenie 10 I don't
know pushing the e porn maybe on a very
good day like Queen c-46 could actually
be some kind of draw okay maybe I can
after all this stuff finally move my
bishop somewhere to be four to the
successes like completely unexpected
activity Bishop before Bishop t6 there's
something wrong with that move Queen B 5
i've got eat six right this is getting
interesting kg for hangs check here so
doing anything probably not
came from the 36 not even here there's
some kind of chance check it's got to be
one awesome Wow I mean okay it was lost
anyway but I really making it very easy
for him very easy Ruby one
so hi mo sang kho sacrificed probably
worked you want also wins anyone
anything wins night b3 I really hated to
give away games with one movers so that
really everybody will win against you
yeah I should resign but I'm too mad mad
at myself to do that Czech spy cheeks
check yeah come on it's useless what a
terrible game night resigns I just run
just wrong tonight I am yeah position
was nothing much happening i think it's
got this people on but i don't think it
is anything special it's just a normal
position yeah just Queen d3 of course I
mean I was thinking this this this and
as I said not much happens he's got the
beep horn but it's not going not going
anywhere quickly and this is just giving
it away yeah and really spare the rest
wow yeah what quite a stupid game thanks
for watching